speaking of latin you mentioned that
tyler said
or sorry that you pointed out to tyler
that there was some latin written and it
couldn't this lecture you were giving
but the audio was not let's say it
wasn't all the highest quality for
whatever reason the person who was
recording didn't have a mic on you so
the camera's all the way at the back and
anytime the audience claps oh my gosh my
ears just
almost broke every single time because i
had to turn the volume up so loud to
hear you oh that's too bad between that
and the camera well anyway you mentioned
that
you were pointing out to tyler there's
some part of something written in latin
he said oh i didn't even know you also
mentioned it's to tell them quote
unquote that they dominate so i wasn't
sure who to them and they were referring
to so why don't you talk about that
please yeah okay so that was really
interesting so
uh one thing that was kind of funny
about my friendship with tyler was that
he was part of the space program he's
really integral into the space program
and he launches you know these rockets
and works with spacex and that type of
thing and what i found out which he
actually did not know and i pointed it
out to him was that the whole thing was
a ritual the whole thing got was
ritualized so
they identified certain time periods
astronomically when it would be
beneficial to launch and they also had
the rockets had
um roman gods on them and they also had
latin first century latin not medieval
latin it wasn't catholic latin it was
basically imperialistic latin
and so and everybody had to stay in
their own space like there was a place
where they had to stay they wore the
same clothes for every mission
um and they ate the same food i'm so
sorry to drop are you referring to a
spacex launch i missed that
yeah yeah well not all spacex launches
just certain of them with tyler involved
and so when he would be involved
launching these satellites into space a
lot of times they'd be with spacex
because that's who they used
yeah so they would they would go you
know they've been doing this from it
looks like from the 1950s onward they've
been doing this ritual and they would
even have like a chaplain there and you
know they would it was very very listen
it was very ritualized and so i noticed
that and i asked him about it and i said
do you know that this is first century
latin that's written on
these rockets and he said no i didn't
know that he didn't even know it was
latin and so we read them we i
translated them all and i said this wow
this says that and i said
who up there in space is going to be
reading this like why would you put that
on there you know that seems so strange
and he said well i imagine it's for them
and i said
okay who's who are they you know and so
he did he just didn't say anything
but that's that's what it was
so the two questions that occur is
firstly what did it say and then also
does this mean that elon musk himself
is putting those messages there like
elon is a believer in et's and and so on
or is it just one of the staff members
no no this is beyond this is way before
elon so it has nothing to do with him
um his company is just the company that
puts those does the launches to get the
satellites up but he has nothing to do
with creating the satellites
or of putting the roman stuff on them
nothing at all to do with that that that
was definitely predates him um so what
does it mean though um
yeah what was written on it yeah so to
me it looks like what i what people have
called like exo theology or astro
theology it's this this kind of well i
call it it's not a specific religion but
it's a religiosity of people who
are involved in the space program and
it's this um you know it's roman you
know the united states kind of considers
itself roman look at our you know
architecture and that type of thing
we're like the new imperial
place right and so i think that's what
it has to do with um they're using the
images of gods and goddesses from rome
um and what do the what does the latin
say um here's a here's something for you
to check out
um it's the uh these they they're called
patches
and have you seen those patches okay so
haha we don't know or ha ha but you
don't yeah uh-huh yeah and so a lot of
those are in latin and that's where you
see and a lot of those would be on the
actual satellites
the images would be on the satellites
and then people who were working the
mission they would get the patch
uh-huh and so the haha part was that on
the satellite or that was just on the
patch
usually you just have the god or goddess
and the image like the dragon or
something like that on the satellite
with the latin phrase that accompanies
it and latin phrases are different for
each launch
hmm
you also mentioned there's a picture of
that that you were going to send to the
audience at that time because remember
i'm listening to the lecture and you
said yeah if anyone's interested i'll
email it to you can you email it to me
so i can place it on screen right now
for not right now sorry when i'm editing
this i'll make a note to remind you of
that is that okay yeah i could get it
right now if you want
the image is being displayed right now
so if you're listening to this on the
audio platforms then i recommend you
click the youtube link in the
description
what you're seeing is the high quality
capture unfortunately the source images
are fairly
low you also refer or not you someone
referred to the president as a
short-timer okay what does that mean
yeah so um and i heard i'd heard this
from not just tyler but a lot of the
people who were part of the program
um that presidents are short timers in
the sense that there must be a program
that's not a short time program but a
long time program and therefore the
presidents come and go and therefore
they're not given the information think
of tyler tyler's been doing this since
he was at least 20 years old
and now he's in his 60s i mean that he's
a long-timer and so he has a lot of
information and the presidents don't
have all that information they're only
given the information that they need to
know